lo zaino di papi j
bello stiloso sprezzante e adrenalinico
ma come mai questo zaino si diversifica
da qualsiasi altro zaino per miserabili
ce lo spiega il nostro tecnico
specializzato in science superbelli e
all'avanguardia
buongiorno studentelli and student l
oggi vi spiegherò come mai questo zaino
cambierà la vostra vita totalmente per
prima cosa lo zaino di fa vj e spazioso
potrete metterci dentro quello che
volete senza alcun problema di spazio di
peso perché lo zaino è dotato di una
particolare magia che fa sparire le cose
quando le inserite
ormai ragazzi lo usano tutti quanti e il
trend del momento pensate che lo usa che
non ha pantella ma quando quanto la
spesa con lo zaino di famiglia la mia
vita non è più la spesa è leggero e non
si sente neanche ma è così bello
continua che non mangio è un mago no ti
prego ma anche faccio tutto quello che
vuoi ma ma abbiamo anche raccolto varie
testimonianze di persone che utilizzano
gli accessori di fa vj ai quali gli è
cambiata praticamente la vita tagli ma
basta co sti youtubers materia di
portare con la scuola stoffa vigenti ma
per favore stai zitta che non capisci un
cazzo
certo che sembrano un
il valore però non è che cipro
costringerla foreste minchiate già la
mia dignità e sotto i piedi però non ci
puoi far fare ste robe ragazzi più devo
cancellare il canale un'acqua scelta
somma cancella camerale più semplice di
così ora piuttosto titolo heiner tito
danilo cretino no ti do ti do ya prendi
jacopo che quello bello guardare via con
lo zaino di fa vj non dovrete più temere
le interrogazioni perché grazie allo
zaino sparirete in un istante quell'ora
e nei diari sono presenti tutti i
videogiochi più belli che ho fatto sul
mio canale e gli ho descritto io stesso
ci ho messo un sacco di impegno ad
esempio gozzi bull ator la vostra vita
non sarà mai più la stessa
oppure con i vari accessori che vedete
sullo sfondo sempre è di fabi jade che
sarei io lorenzo non ci sono le ormai è
così bello così
e lucy 7 mian che mai così bello